hello everyone and welcome to a
wonderful game that just finished from
the Ulus bar generation cup it is a part
of the Champions Chester and it is um
azerbaijani Grandmaster Iden suleimanley
versus uh sorry not Peter swidler
um sorry about that uh against Levon
Aryan and suleimanley is having a great
tournament he already defeated a couple
of very strong players he defeated nihal
sarin he'll feed the nijigiri and in the
previous round he defeated Maxima grab
and now he faces lemon in a most
tactical uh frenzy of a game so let's
see what happened here we have Pawn to
C4 Eiden opens with uh the English
opening with Knight to F6 Knight to F3
uh and pawn to E6 with G3 D5 so a pretty
standard neocatalin here Bishop to G2
and pawn to D for now Levon grabs more
space in the center we have castles and
pawn to C5 now he defends his D for Pawn
E3 and Knight to C6 all been played
before again nothing new here captures
captures Rook D1 and the bishop to D6 we
have D3 H6 and now Knight beta D2 We
have Castles by Levon uh A3 preparing B4
and of course A5 stopping V4 and there
are a couple of games that reach this
position
uh Rook to B1 is a normal Queen to C2 is
a normal but here uh we have uh Knight
the E4 and it is now as of move 12 that
we have a completely new game so this is
where our game basically begins let's
see uh how Levon treats this Knight the
E4 novelty uh he says all right Knight
captures on e4 if this was any good
someone would already play it uh Rook
captures and just Pawn to E5 Now The
Rook um doesn't have all that much to do
here Bishop Dev 5 can be played Pawn to
F5 can be played uh Knight the H4 and
now Rook to B8 interestingly if F5 this
looks great for black but after The Rook
moves there's just no good follow-up you
don't have E4 you don't have F4 and you
have someone to weakened your king so
I'll live on uh wait with that he plays
Rook the B8 and now Queen to H5 Iden
brings the queen into the attack and now
you have to be a little bit worried the
bishop is here the Knight is here The
Queen Is Here The Rook is here if the if
the Rook moves then Bishop to E4 can
happen uh and um if LeBron just plays
for example B5 he did play Rook to B8 so
B5 is not out of the question uh then
you would run into Bishop captures on H6
and after G characters Queen characters
item would give up two pieces for the uh
two points two pieces for the sorry two
a piece for uh two uh pawns and uh he
would just get a very nice attack like I
said three of the attackers are already
here if the Rook moves the bishop can
come over to claim this diagonal so it
would be white who would be fighting for
the win here so instead Queen F6 level
not to be tricked easily and now Pawn to
F4 of course you want to open up lines
of attack towards the black king you
want to move the bishop and then bring
the Rook into the game as well uh Bishop
to D7 and now Pawn to F5 just grabbing
more space here and believe it or not
here at 11 played B5 and he is dead lost
however this is rapid time format uh 10
10 plus zero and uh I didn't missed it
do you guys see how you can win this
game uh really really quickly with white
uh feel free to pause the video and win
it while I give you a couple of seconds
uh for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on finding this
Unstoppable attack and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is
Rook the G4 so simply it's so elegant uh
black is without a move uh next move
Bishop captures on H6 is happening and
then you just get absolutely destroyed
and you might think well okay let's just
move the king and our g-pawn isn't
pinned that's absolutely true but now
your H Pawn is pinned and now Bishop to
G5 wins The Black Queen so remarkable
but of course I didn't did not even
think for a second that Lavon would Bond
or something like this you just don't
expect that from a such a player and he
played his next move G4 with maybe
within three seconds so yeah a tough
break for him but luckily Levon did not
stop the attack with G5 lemon continued
playing uh on the queen side he played B
captures on C4 and now G5 is incredibly
strong we have Pawn to G6 now attacking
um uh Islands Queen and now F captures
on G6 with f captures and G6 again
attacking his Queen and Knight captures
and G6 Queen to F2 with check King to H1
and now Rook to F7
um uh sorry King stage one first and
Rook to F7 and now uh White is again
completely winning but you have to find
the correct idea there are many
possibilities here and two of them are
very good so I'm sure you guys already
uh have some ideas of course Rook the E2
comes to mind the kick off the queen
from such an active square but the
really strong move is the one that
always eludes us and that of course is a
move with the Knight back and uh
Suleiman like I said this is a 10 minute
rapid game he spent he had some uh four
minutes and 50 seconds when he started
thinking in this position and he spent
four minutes uh he he was down to 57
seconds when he played this move he
played Knight to H4 and now the threat
of Queen G6 check and winning the bishop
is simply too powerful also G6 is coming
you can just start capturing uh it's
hard to hard to uh even start pairing
all of the threats here and the point is
if you let's play let's say play G7
ninjas G6 and now Bishop captures on H6
and that's pretty much it black has no
play the Knight Bishop the other Bishop
The Rook The Rook none of them are part
of this game and the queen alone can't
really do all that much uh regardless of
how close she is to the white king so
after Knight to H4 C captures on D3
livon decided to play actively and okay
I didn't accept the challenge uh Queen
to G6 with check Rook to G7 and now
Queen captures on D6 also puts pressure
on The Rook here so you can't move the
knight uh Rook to f8 and now Pawn to G6
uh now the pawn here is incredibly
strong also Bishop captures and H6 is an
idea but now Ponte D2 traps the bishop
here but not a problem Bishop captures
Queen captures and now Rook captures on
E5 giving up the exchange and completely
shattering levon's position here the
problem is if you take then comes Bishop
to D5 with check and then if Knight the
F7 or you give up the Knight doesn't
really matter G captures with check you
can't move the king otherwise the queen
captures and if it happens so you have
to play Rook G captures on F7 then comes
Rook to G1 this with Tempo the black
king is in check King H7 and now Bishop
captures on F7 and black is just down
too much material without any real
counter play Rogue captures Queen to G6
with check King to h8 and of course even
Checkmate can happen
so after root captures on E5 uh Rook to
F2 was played instead and now still
Bishop to D5 with check King to h8 and
now Rook to F5 giving up more material
uh looking for Bishop characters than F5
uh it wasn't played but even if it was
uh of course just Queen to f8 would
check Rook to j8 and this will be
Checkmate so instead I have to look at
five and Knight the E7 attacking the
bishop and Rook here and now just The
Rook captures on F2 Queen captures an F2
and now Queen captures on D7 and with
the light Square Bishop guarding this
diagonal the white king really has no no
enemies for the rest of the game Queen
captures an H4 Queen to d8 with check
this is a very nasty check because you
can't even block with the Knight block
with the Knight then the queen and H4
hangs uh so instead after Queen 38 would
check Rook to G8 was played and now just
Pawn to G7 uh beautiful absolutely
stunning uh what can what can you do if
you go King to H7 which kind of makes
sense then just Bishop captures and G8
with check uh and uh if you play Knight
captures then just Queen captures and H4
we said that if the Knight moves um
that's a big problem and if King
captures then Rook to G1 check and again
you get absolutely destroyed here you're
done a full Rook uh no point in playing
this so after G7 check King captures was
played right away Rook to G1 with check
and now King to F6 and here Queen to D6
check was played and he was in this
position on move 36 that level and
arunian resigned to the game as there is
nothing more to be done here uh two more
moves can be played King to F5 and after
Queen to E6 with check King to F4 uh
Queen to E4 will be checkmate
so brilliantly done by a 18 year old
Aiden suleimanley first defeating and
nijigiri then Maxim vashir lagrav then
Levon arunyan and while I'm recording
this video he's actually playing against
none other than alireza firuja so I I
can check how that game is going if you
guys want uh if you don't want me to
spoil it for you don't listen but uh I'm
gonna mention it now so he played
alireza and he lost that game so he had
that he had a great run but then then
came alireza and that was it uh so yeah
there we have it very nicely done
beautiful beautiful attack he found this
new Moon Knight to E4 uh Levon treated
it well but at some point you know it
was just uh the attack was too strong
and even this is beautiful and it like
always my favorite part when you play a
strong player like a former 2800 player
you just don't expect him to make such a
blunder that you can play Rook G4 and
you win there's no move either you get
checkmated or you you trap The Black
Queen but yeah I mean crazy stuff what
do you want to do uh so yeah once again
really hope you guys enjoyed it if you
have any uh other game that you would
like seeing uh do use hashtag suggestion
and I will go over it there are so many
games being played I cannot cover all of
that I cannot uh you know follow all of
them uh so if you have a nice one just
send me a link via email via Twitter you
know via any social platform and I will
always very gladly receive it so yeah
once again really hope you guys enjoyed
it I would like to thank Gary trommel
Rod Hill uh Leonidas Frederick Carson
and Christopher Mark for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the Chess World uh thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day